Welcome to elementary statistics.
We're really excited
to have you on board.
My name's Katie, and
I'm the one who'll be explaining most
of the concepts throughout this course.
I'll also be doing a lot of drawing and
a lot of writing to help you understand
the content as much as possible.
In each of the 16
lessons in this course,
you'll learn new methods to describe and
analyze data.
Each lesson builds on
the concepts you learned before.
So as you progress through the course
try to get a good grasp of the material
before moving on.
But if it turns out you need a review,
no big deal.
You can easily go back and re-watch
the videos and redo the exercises.
What do I mean by exercises?
Each lesson consists of
short instructional videos
where I explain cool step stuff and
guide your thinking.
But we want you to make
breakthroughs on your own.
So instead of just telling you a fact or
formula, I'll ask a quiz.
A quiz or exercise,
same thing, is not there for
us to judge you or to impact your grade.
It's there for your own benefit,
to make you think.
At Udacity, we believe that the chance
to think about something from your
own unique perspective is
a powerful learning opportunity.